tengo muchas ganas de intentar probar
que raíz de 2 es irracional y justo eso
es lo que vamos a ver en este vídeo
vamos a intentar demostrar que raíz de 2
es irracional que raíz o keeffe raíz que
la is de 2 es irracional irracional
ahora para ver qué raíz de 2 es
irracional voy a utilizar la
contradicción
voy a demostrar que raíz de 2 es
racional por el método de contradicción
y para esto lo que hay que hacer es
suponer justo lo contrario y para saber
que vamos a llegar a algo absurdo a una
contradicción así que bueno tras lo que
voy es probar que raíz de dos racional
déjenme tratando con este color y lo voy
a probar por contradicción por
contradicción le voy a poner aquí
demostración de postración demostración
por contradicción por contradicción
ahora date cuenta de que si yo llego a
un absurdo suponiendo lo contrario es
decir que raíz de dos es racional
entonces cuando llegue a ese absurdo que
estoy buscando en ese momento estoy
diciendo que raíz de 2 debería de ser
irracional que es justo lo que nosotros
queremos ok entonces la idea de esto es
suponer que raíz de 2 es racional y lo
voy a poner aquí raíz de 2
racional vamos a suponer que raíz de dos
es racional y vamos a ver si llegamos a
un absurdo y si decimos que raíz de dos
es racional entonces podemos decir
entonces podemos decir que raíz de dos
raíz de dos lo puedo ver como una
fracción como una razón entre dos
enteros entonces a raíz de 2 le voy a
escribir como a una división entre dos
números enteros
entre a voy a utilizar este color entre
b / b ok ahora lo importante de todo
esto es ver que a y b es decir esta
fracción que tenga aquí es una fracción
irreducible y eso es muy importante si
esta fracción no fue reducible bueno
pues entonces podemos sacar algún factor
común cancelarlo y tarde o temprano en
llegar a una fracción irreducible todas
las fracciones después de reducirlas
llegan a ser una fracción irreductible
y eso es súper importante para esta
demostración que esta fracción es
reducible o dicho de otra manera que a b
sólo tienen como factor común al 1 lo
que es exactamente lo mismo que decir
que iverson q primos o primos relativos
entre sí ok entonces yo es lo que quiero
ver o más bien yo lo que voy a suponer
es que esta fracción es una fracción
irreducible aquí está la clave de esta
demostración y
si le ok voy a suponer que esta fracción
de este reducible y si eso es cierto
estoy diciendo que a ibn
ok a y b y b son primos relativos entre
sí o son co primos o podemos decir que
no tienen no
tienen no tienen ningún factor común
y ninguno
factor común exacto
común común
que no sea el 11 de septiembre
ok y esto es muy importante raíz de 2 lo
vamos a ver como una fracción
irreducible todas las fracciones las
podemos llevar a una fracción es
reducible y eso quiere decir que tanto a
como ven no tienen ningún factor común
excepto el 1 excepto el 1 ok ahora
utilizando esta misma información
manipulamos justo esto que tenemos aquí
si esto es cierto esto quiere decir que
raíz de dos lo voy a poner se raíz de 2
es lo mismo que a entre ve que hay entre
b entre b ok y de aquí que te parece si
elevó al cuadrado ambos lados de esta
igualdad llegarían a que 2 a que 2 es
exactamente lo mismo que a cuadrada que
a cuadrada entre b cuadrada entre b
cuadrada y lo único que estoy haciendo
es elevando el cuadrado a ambos lados de
esta igualdad elevó al cuadrado
la raíz de 2 y el cuadrado con la raíz
se va y aquí me queda a cuadrada entre b
cuadrada o dicho de otra manera esto es
exactamente
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que poner
que 22 por ver cuadrada 2 por b cuadrada
y bueno estoy suponiendo que es distinto
de 0 esto es exactamente igual esto es
exactamente igual que a cuadrada que a
cuadrado lo único que hice fue
multiplicar esta igualdad de ambos lados
por b cuadrado de tal manera que aquí se
va a cancelar y solamente me queda
cuadrada mientras que del lado izquierdo
me queda dos veces b cuadrada ok qué
quiere decir esto bueno pues lo que
quiero que veas es que aquí podemos
concluir a y vamos a ponerlo así aquí
podemos concluir que a cuadrada debe de
ser un número par tanto a como b son
enteros precisamente de aquí nos tomamos
una fracción que es una división de
enteros y aquí yo tengo dos por un
número entero dos por un número entero
esto me da un número par por lo tanto
cuando yo tengo un número entero y lo
multiplicó por dos es un número par que
es el valor de a cuadrado
y entonces puedo decir que al cuadrado
es
muy bien y esto para qué nos sirve bueno
porque si a cuadrada spam y es que
quiero que recuerdes cuadrada es lo
mismo que decir a por am a por am
entonces es park spark y esto para qué
porque quiero que recuerdes un poco algo
de lo que hemos visto si yo tengo por
ejemplo un número par a un número par lo
multiplicó por un número par bueno pues
esto sabemos que nos da un número par un
número par 2 x 2 es 48 por 8 74 y si yo
tengo un número impar un número impar y
a éste lo multiplicó por un número del
par lo multiplicó por un número impar
obtengo un número impar obtengo un
número impar eso qué quiere decir bueno
que si par por par nos da un número par
entonces ahora nos da un número par y
esto esto quiere decir que a
spa es para la única manera de que
tengamos un número x sí mismo que nos dé
un número par debe de ser que este
número sea un número par o dicho de otra
manera podemos decir y déjame cambiar de
color para que lo veas con
este color dicho de otra manera podemos
decir que a lo podemos escribir lo
podemos escribir como un número par es
decir como dos veces un cierto número de
ok como aes par lo podemos ver como dos
veces acá porque este de kim es un
número par ok y bueno para que todo esto
porque cuando nosotros decimos que es un
número par y lo podemos representar aquí
ahora voy a utilizar esta información
para sustituir a aquí y llegar a que b
también es un número par piensa en un
segundo por ahí va la clave para llegar
a la contradicción si nosotros vemos que
b es un número par entonces estamos
llegando a una contradicción de que esta
fracción sea
y tras eso vamos ok como lo podemos ver
como 2 camps qué te parece si lo
sustituimos justo en esta ecuación que
tengo aquí y me va a quedar que dos
veces ven a me lo voy a poner aquí dos
veces ven a ve cuadrada dos veces ve
cuadrada de cuadrada esto es exactamente
lo mismo esto es exactamente lo mismo
estoy escribiendo esta cuestión aquí que
a cuadrada pero lo podemos ver como dos
acá y esto elevado al cuadrado es decir
esto es lo mismo que dos k elevado al
cuadrado lo que representa al cuadrado
solamente estoy sustituyendo en esta
ecuación y bueno de aquí puede obtener
que dos veces ven dos veces b cuadrada
es exactamente lo mismo y aquí voy a
elevar al cuadrado y me queda cuatro
veces cada cuadra la cuatro veces que
cuadrada o dicho de otra manera si
divido todo entre dos voy a llegar a que
este ese color debe el color de b&b
cuadrada es exactamente lo mismo
dos veces que cuadrada que dos veces
campo cuadrada lo único que hice fue
dividir esta parte entre dos y esta
parte también la divide entre dos y
justo estoy llegando a que b cuadrada es
igual a 2 camps cuadrada lo que quiere
decir por el mismo razonamiento un
razonamiento muy análogo que ve cuadrada
y aquí estoy diciendo que ve cuadrada
debe de ser un número par debe cuadrada
es par porque lo puedo representar como
dos veces un cierto número y sirve
cuadrada spark ok de aquí puede obtener
que debe de ser par de spar por el mismo
razonamiento de aquí arriba par por
palmer debe de dar un número par y sirve
cuadrada spark forzosamente b debe de
ser par ok de aquí me fui para acá y de
aquí me fui para acá y entonces estoy
diciendo que es
un número que yo puedo hacer como ambas
escribirlo así ave ave lo puedo ver de
la siguiente manera dos veces dos veces
un cierto número m y justo aquí es donde
cae la contradicción y aquí es lo más
importante de este vídeo
si b es igual a dos veces e m y ya es
igual a dos veces acá tienen un factor
común que es 2 tanto b es par como a
spark y justo habíamos dicho que entre b
en una fracción irreducible si ya
entrevé es una fracción irreducible
entonces tanto a como b no tienen ningún
factor común pero acabamos de encontrar
que éste tiene un factor común y luego
aquí está lo malo del asunto esto es una
contradicción acabo de llegar a algo que
no se puede porque habíamos supuesto
justo lo contrario
esta es una contradicción lo que me está
diciendo que entonces raíz de todos no
puede ser racional porque justo de aquí
partimos y si raíz de 2 no puede ser
racional estoy diciendo
que ya llegamos a nuestro resultado
estoy diciendo que raíz de 2 es
irracional nosotros empezamos diciendo
que raíz de 12 racional entonces lo
podemos ver como a entre una fracción
irreducible y esto quiere decir que hay
b no tiene ningún factor común excepto
el 1 y llegamos a que hay b tienen como
factor común al 2 y entonces aquí se da
la contradicción y en ese momento
podemos concluir entonces que raíz de 2
debe de ser irracional